what is happening there reject nation
greg and
john here we are going to watch from a
great youtube channel called think story
channel link in the description box and
pin comment for this guy
56 key differences between mortal kombat
95
and mortal kombat 2021 i've been waiting
for a video like this to check out and
react to mortal kombat 95
i love the hell out of that movie and i
would like to see a breakdown
pointing it out seriously subscribe to
think story if you haven't done so
already his channel is well worth it
deserves way more subscribers check out
more of his videos when you get the
chance our mortal kombat
reaction watch along recycle the time
code is over at our patreon page right
now the reaction highlights
there is a little problem with the
footage but it's also fixed now so it's
being edited hopefully we'll be up this
week
let's get into this
come on back to the year 1995 where the
internet came in cereal boxes and i
didn't have to pay rent to live in my
parents basement
it's also the year mortal combat was
released spending three weeks at the top
of the box office and making over 122
million
fast forward 26 years later and warner
brothers hopes to reboot this struggling
franchise after the disaster that was
mortal combat annihilation
so in this video i thought it would be
fun to compare the original 1995 mortal
kombat to the
2021 version yes what's different what's
the same
and why didn't goro get punched in the
dick
[Music]
got to hurt i don't care where you're
from so make sure to like and subscribe
because here we go right off the bat we
have our first difference the
warner brothers logo you won't see this
on the 95 version
as it was distributed by new life acted
as the production company for the 2021
release remember that boppin techno mix
from the original
well it doesn't quite fit the tone of
2021's beginning and only really
it would have been really fun if it did
funny to see
someone recut that and that's because
the intro here is of tranquil 1617 japan
the original doesn't have any flashbacks
at all it does however have nightmares
which both
versions incorporate and while both
these versions help set up the mortal
kombat tournament they go about it in
two wildly different ways
in 95 our protagonist is lou kang who
joins the tournament to avenge the death
of his brother chan at the hands of
shang tsun
fun fact the actor who plays chan was
also the stunt coordinator
on the bachelor okay what
cat cat oh my gosh kylie
fatality the 20 20 i do want to get this
out of the way
i think the performances and the
character depiction of liu kang and
shang tsung
i much more prefer the 95 version over
the 2021 version i think overall even
just looking at the imagery i still
prefer the
95 version it's more lovable it's got
more personality
more color feels more lived in actually
and the world feels bigger whereas in
the
mortal kombat 2021 movie it kind of
feels like a fan fiction play
yeah because they keep talking about
like big world
events it kind of feels like a bigger
budget web series in a way it really
stood out to me during the scene
when shang tsung has like the great
natara prince goro they're saying all
these like big labels and titles
but i'm like but where's the civilians
and worlds around you
all this yeah just seeing these like
characters and titles
giving me exposition but like even here
in the 95
clips you're seeing like background
extras and all that you know it feels
like
yeah like a populated world rather than
cutting around to just like a couple
remote locations
yeah and then with characters just
talking next position yeah i i think
there's more personality in the 95 one
for sure
the 2021 version sets up our new
protagonist cole young's bloodline and
how he's connected to the great warrior
hanzo hasashi who will become one of
mortal kombat's most famous fighters
scorpion a huge difference between these
versions are how they treat
scorpion and sub-zero original these
fighters are completely one-dimensional
and basically are just there to look
cool
and say their catchphrases get over here
in fact i don't think
sub-zero says anything at all whereas
the 2021 version has them completely
fleshed out with backstage says
so much you may notice hanzo here
carrying these buckets of water which
are the same type of buckets luke king
uses to defeat sub-zero
we also get our first close-up of
scorpion's iconic spear tip
in the original it has more of an
organic quality while here it's made of
steel and more faithful to the game
we also see that it's i think a lot of
people including myself
because of the movie when i saw it i was
like oh but i realized that kane comes
out of scorpion's hand
like so for the longest time i believed
that it came out of his hand because of
the 95 movie dude it's like the
spider-man wrist web shooters of mortal
kombat
yes a lot of people thought that that
was just natural to spider-man until
they were like nope this is a sam raimi
thing i mean yeah one thing for sure
though that this mortal kombat 2021
movie does have over the 95 one is
there's their actual characters here on
scorpio
we also see that it's johnny cage
fighting scorpion here and johnny's
absence from the 2021 version is one of
the biggest differences between the two
films
however we do find out cole is on his
way to hollywood
in search of johnny at the end in the
original we see
johnny on set with a director who looks
suspiciously like
steven spielberg hey he might even be on
the set of citizen cage which we see a
poster of near the end
play on words of citizen kane the 1941
classic
i would love if that's what he's
actually filming and it's a call back to
the 95 movie that would be really clever
if they did that in the sequel did
something where
they go to the new johnny cage and it
looks like it's out of the 95 mortal
kombat movie where he's on set
yeah it's like the same movie like wait
a minute this looks like the 95 here
yeah you get actual steven
how we don't see his face here likely
because they haven't cast him yet
raiden's role in the right
conversion is way more hands-off than it
is
it's also taken a lot more seriously the
fate of
billions will depend upon you
raiden is the protector of earth realm
and he feels a lot more human in the
original as opposed to the constantly
glowing eyes of the 2021 version
his powers are also vastly expanded but
that has likely more to do with the
advancement in visual effects more than
anything else
we see this with other characters as
well like liu king's fireball and dragon
apparition or
sub-zero's ice wall the closest we get
to liu kang having supernatural powers
in the original is the final blast he
gives to shang soon
characters like sonia never even get
powers in the original unless you count
her death by vagina move
guess that's what you call that you know
it's weird as a as a man who
who's really proud of the asian
representation on screen especially as
of late in hollywood i do prefer
christopher lambert's version of raiden
because his version
did feel more human not just because of
the glowing eyes thing he feels like an
actual mentor who's like
humor is meant as a way to still guide
or provoke in a certain direction
to get them on the track he wants him to
be on to be the saviors of earth realm
whereas like raiden in this one he looks
cooler like raiden's aesthetic is so
much cooler but he's kind of like this
cynical angry guy he's just like
kung lao and liu kang you do all the
training the actor has a presence
but yeah as a character he's got way
less personality
yeah he does get hanzo's baby and help
carry on the bloodline
uh so i still liked him but yeah i mean
he's nowhere near as as like
fun to watch is christopher the 2021
version gets a lot of the exposition out
of the way by showing this
title card explaining how shang soon is
one mortal kombat victory away from
being able to take over earthrealm
in the original this is all done through
dialogue from raiden the main difference
here however is this talk about
bloodlines and prophecy which are
entirely new
the 95 version dabbles a bit with liu
kang and destiny but there's
no mention of a prophecy and outworld
during the daytime something you don't
see in the original although both
versions do visit this realm the new
version
shows what appears to be shang tsun's
throne in the original the fighters
battle him in his castle which isn't
depicted in the 2021 version
we do however get these cloaked citizens
of outworld
just like the original and a giant stone
statue of prince goro
some of you may forget but jax is
actually in the original
for a total of 10 seconds he's recast an
annihilation
i trust one person on this planet jack
you're talking to her
here his character is way more fleshed
out having become a champion himself
after tracking down a target with his
partner sonia blade in brazil
and obtaining his dragon mark that's
something that we gotta get credit for
jax is much better oh
yeah yeah he's a character for real i
mean you got the depiction of him the
10-second win in mortal kombat 1.
he's in mortal kombat annihilation he
needs like fun he or he
like he was someone i actually did care
for in this film a nice physical
performance do you see what i mean when
they're like cutting around to the
differences at outworld here
they do all this like big world talk of
like everything that's at stake and
legacy and lore but then
it just feels like fan fiction play
because you're not getting the sense of
the world
yeah world just feels like a desolate
kind of crappy place to be in the new
year
like where do these people live no
wonder you want to take over earth realm
you're sick of being in out and outwards
do y'all just sleep on the ground here
or where are you going you do mine
rocks and fight all day unlike the
original these dragon marks play a large
role in the new version
they designate who will become a
champion and who can unlock something
known as
arcana this concept was never discussed
or shown in the original but it's what
locks one's powers is
different for each individual shang soon
tasks sub-zero with tracking down and
killing earth's champions the ones with
this mark
unlike the original shang tsung doesn't
invite them to participate in a battle
on his secluded island he decides to
break the rules established by the elder
gods
not mentioned in the 2021 version is his
allegiance to shao khan the emperor we
do see a statue of him at the end of the
95 version he makes a brief appearance
setting him up as the main villain for
mortal kombat
annihilation god that has been a meme
going
introduces us to the beauty of gary
indiana sonia here acts as mrs
exposition teaching us more about the
tournament and how the dragon marks work
in all fairness they all act as mrs
exposition yep
except for kano and cole young is mr
listening to exposition
he's us we even get a glimpse of what
could be the character nighthawk not
featured in either versions however
there is one line of dialogue in the
original that does mention him
i'm going to need a seeing eye dog shang
soon tasmolina was sending
wolf yeah i think that line was you're
gonna need a seeing eye dog
that that shang tsung just said yeah
still subscriber things still subscribe
hey man we all we all
wonder sometimes a lot of great points
and i know people have the habit of
harping on the little
errors but you know we'll point it out
for you but i'm sure there's a billion
comments whoever already done it for you
shang soon tasmolina was sending out
saizoth
also known as reptilian reptile looks a
lot better here than he does in the
original
that makes her step sisters with
princess katana who we do see in the
original
we might not see her in the 2020 version
but we definitely do see katana's iconic
steel fans in the background
i didn't notice that
shang island jackson sonia worked
together as part of the special forces
an organization created by the us
government to bring down the black
dragon and red dragon clans
melina dies in the 2021 version no one
really dies do they
she'll come back with a different
colored costume next hopefully yeah i
think you gotta have
especially if you do a sequel and
katanas in there you gotta have katana
and molina
have a face off man yeah you gotta do it
maybe that will be
the scorpion sub-zero flashback that
starts the whole movie
yeah woke now yeah
[Music]
is the leader of the black dragons which
steal into legal arms trades
among other things when we first meet
him in the original he already has his
iconic
red eye the one with silver plating well
in this version he
learns this ability as part of his
arcana although he does have a red eye
in the original we
never see him use it there kano ends up
joining forces with cole and sonia for a
short time and even uses his trademark
heart rip out fatality which originated
from the video game
something we don't see in the original
in fact the word fatality which has
become synonymous with the game
only is spoken once in both movies once
when shang tsung sucks the soul out of a
guy who loses to liu kang
and once when kung lao brutally severs
natara in half which i can't even show
or else my video will get demonetized
upon arriving at raven's temple we're
introducing
in the original this name is only
mentioned once kung lao being an ancient
ancestor of liu kangs this kung lao is
named after the same ancestor and it's
hinted at that liu kang and kung lao
could be
cousins a fun addition to the 2021
version is when liu kang challenges the
champions to test their might a mini
game found in the original video game
but never mentioned in the original film
speaking oh
that's clever that's cool version like
how he was an orphan picked up by raiden
this isn't really delved too deeply in
the original and more focus is placed on
his relationship with his brother chan
something not mentioned in the new
version shang soon tests some more
memorable mk characters with defeating
the champions
see i think that's something the 95
version definitely got down better was
even though it like it's still cheesy
and stuff that whole thing with lou
king's brother
and even with sonia blade and kano
there's
there's a more personal vibe for why
they're
in the tournament even if it's cheesy
it's a different level of investment put
into it
and it's like a very 90s thing i feel
like sure have some kind of element
where it's like oh yeah my brother and
then he died and i'm partly fighting for
his honor no matter how cheesy that gets
there's like something that plucks your
heart's strengths about it
characters aren't seen in the original
and include natara cabal and general
ryko most notable among them is cabal
who has history with kano
also being a member of the black dragon
clan it was kano who healed cabal and
gave him his respiratory mask which he
calls an iron lung
in the new version kino ends up double
crossing the champions by destroying
raiden's staff which seems to be
protecting the temple this staff is
never seen in the original
meanwhile while cole goes back home here
we go
one million dollar animatronics really
a dozen puppeteers to operate there are
four really
having dialogue as well in the new
version he's basically in one scene to
fight coal with the purpose of coal
discovering his arcana
he's a bit more green in tone and
completely cgi
cole ends up killing goro with his
newfound power while in the original
he's killed by johnny cage after falling
off a cliff but i want to hear
which goro version you guys like more in
the comments below
i prefer the 95 goro version i mean
there's something about having it
actually be there that's just so much
more charming i guess like i like the
new one like i thought it looked good
but yeah i mean at the end of the day
which one do you want to cuddle there's
something that's effective about the 95
version with goro where he has a real
presence about him here they go prince
goro
then he shows up and he just fights cole
young in the 95 one like like when he's
talking with kano like it seems scary to
be around this guy
goro defeats johnny cage's friend and i
cared more about that death than i did
about
kung lao dying to be honest they have
that montage where goro's like knocking
everyone to the ground you're building
him up
the design is even scarier to me yeah
well i think he works better in the
tournament environment than just like uh
be my assassin go to earth kung lao says
the iconic flawless victory
line here while in the original that
line is only spoken by shang soon sonia
ends up killing kano stabbing him
through the eye with a garden gnome
and i wonder if he'll be resurrected in
future sequels with that new
iron eye plate liu kang's fight with
cabal has him using his trademark
bicycle kick move while this same move
is performed by him against
reptile in the original cole is tasked
with taking on sub-zero but is helped by
his ancestor scorpion who has emerged
from the depths of hell in the original
scorpion transports johnny cage to a
hell type location where they fight he
even uses his skull
breath which we see in addition in both
versions
with sub-zero defeated scorpion says he
is now well i did like about seeing the
the fire move too in the mortal kombat
in the 2021
movie is that you do see him actually
set someone's epidermis on fire
shang soon is set up to be a recurring
villain swearing he'll bring
armies next time they see each other in
the original
background
whether or not this reboot is a success
and the actor who played sub-zero has
already signed on for four more mortal
kombat movies
should the studio decide to play so it
looks like if the movie does well
sub-zero won't be the only thing that
survives thanks for watching everyone
check out my mortal kombat ending
explained video for an even deeper
analysis of the story
and make sure to like subscribe and
share this video for more bad takes you
can always follow me on twitter and
instagram at thingstoryt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
yeah i mean short summary version would
be there are definitely parts of the
2021 movie
that i prefer overall i still prefer the
95 movie i haven't
i definitely enjoy that one more it's
easily the more cuddly and the one you
would throw on just as comfort food
i think this is a good first step still
and i'm totally down for a sequel and i
think if
you know now that warner brothers seems
to have faith in this franchise
after the success that it's garnered i
think they will be able to
take its time more listen to some of the
criticisms to really improve the film
and i feel like they could do a sequel
that is much better
i have faith that the sequel can
actually do a much better job than the
2021 version yeah absolutely always
championing it for the filmmakers man
anyway guys what did you think about
this which mortal kombat do you prefer
leave your thoughts down below subscribe
click that notification bell
subscribe to think story last but not
least let's shout out some patrons
chris bustin mr crispy
simon schnell stone pc
ventilizer jesse dobby
reactions today pancakes
alex biewer morgan
kathleen marr as our sabir
hussein pseudonymous entity
olivia delgade t magic
infinity john byers
kevin cassimero differently sign
nash senediki kelly ales
chase jacob gonzalez levitt odell
harvards josh barnes sean davis
oscar thank you guys so much for
pledging
you guys rock you're the best hopefully
you can help us restore the snyder verse
sign that petition
seriously your support means a lot thank
you for being part of patreon we'll see
you guys soon
you